all right so um
i'm about to throw you into the next
part here um 14c here it is now this
looks a lot more disgusting because you
don't have the um the added value of a
diagram that does a lot of thinking for
you but i promise i mean look at this
it's the same number of marks right one
mark two marks um this first question or
first part rather once you see through
like well where did that you know um n
choose k notation come from once you're
willing to push past that just a little
bit you'll see why it's only worth one
mark and part two should fall out if
you're careful with your algebra and
your trigonometric identities um because
i mean
it doesn't take someone who's an expert
at extension two to see this is a
trigonometric identities question all
right so it's 2 31 i'm gonna give you
about four minutes to have a go at this
so 2 35 by my clock will come back
together as usual just post in the chat
if you've got any questions you're like
i'm struggling i need a hint you're
welcome to do it privately if you prefer
or let us know if you're like oh that
question was surprisingly quick i am
totally done um and with any luck we
might even be able to finish this lesson
early i better not jinx it so there you
go four minutes good luck
i think that's probably enough time for
you to make um even if you're not
finished enough progress that we can uh
helpfully work through this together
okay so let's start off and as promised
even though it's very intimidating i
think you'll find part one pretty
trivial so if you were like held up by
it i think that's a lesson to you that
it's like even when it's a little bit
gross looking um don't be don't freak
out it's actually often quite manageable
once you see through the notation okay
it says given a positive integer and
show that and then they take this sec to
the 2n theta so just remember what that
means right that's just sec theta
raised to the power of 2n show that it's
equal to and then they use sigma
notation here to indicate that there's
an expansion going on here right so you
can see here it's like oh this thing
raised to a power um if you can use some
identity in here it's going to if you
think about the pythagorean identity in
fact if we didn't take out that 2 if
we've been left inside you've got a sec
squared there and you can do a
substitution i'm going to show you in a
second which will get us over into the
land of tan okay now um
uh it's not a very well kept secret that
i have a horrendous memory so
even though i just referred to the
pythagorean identity just now i have
never ever once remembered like and i've
been teaching for like 15 years i've
never remembered the actual trig
identity for sec or for cot or anything
like that i just remembered like the
vanilla version um which let's write our
part one working here which is just sine
squared plus cos squared equals one
because it's not very hard to get from
this to any other identity that you need
if you want things in terms of sec
squared you're dividing through by think
about it think about it
you're dividing through by cos squared
right and that's what will give you the
sec squared on the right hand side so
all you need to do is well if you divide
that through by sex squared you get tan
squared that'll become one and then here
comes sec squared on the right hand side
now in order to get us up to this result
up here as i said having the sex squared
there in the brackets all i really need
to do is to raise both sides to the
power of m okay now please note here i'm
just going to write this in blue you're
raising the entire side um you're not
raising just those particular
trigonometric terms and sadly this is
actually a common error that students
made don't write this down but when they
said oh i need to raise this sec to the
power of n this sex squared to the
paraben i should have said um i also
need to raise the um tan squared to the
power of n and they wrote something like
this um you know press f in the chat for
everyone who tried this because you
couldn't get any further if you wrote
this down because
you're like oh where's my signal
notation like there's nothing to expand
right so um yeah don't do that that's
that's a bad idea okay
now once you've got this the left-hand
side is fine or rather the right-hand
side which will become the left-hand
side is fine it says
to the power of 2n theta and then over
on the right hand side i just need to do
a very brief expansion here right um i'm
going to do my binomial coefficients so
you start with n because that's the
power that you're raised to
you get the zeroth term first and i'm
actually going to write it sort of
backwards i'm going to treat this as 1
plus tan squared just because of the way
that they've written this result here
right you can see their k is matched up
with this k over here so those powers
match so i essentially want this 0 to be
the 0th power
of tan squared even though normally we
would take the thing that's written
first i'm going to take it second so you
just get an nc 0 out the front
you're going to go over to the next
power there and then you've got a tan
squared i should point out there's
really a 1 to the power of n here and a
1 to the power of n minus 1 here
but because it's just a 1 i don't need
to worry about it doesn't make a
difference how far do i need to go to
establish a pattern answer three terms
generally does it for us right so this
is going to be 10 to the 4 now and then
how far do i need to go well i just want
to get to the end what's the final term
and it's n choose n
you get up to this tan to n theta term
over there and that's pretty much it
right this is i can just use sigma
notation here um to express everything
on that top line just taking it bit by
bit right so i start at zero i go all
the way to n you get your binomial
coefficient out the front and then you
get the the tan term but this is not 10
to the 2n it's 10 to the 2 k because
that k value is the thing it's
incrementing as you go along obviously
you could have used any other letter r
or s or things like that but in the
question they've told us to use k so
that's why i've done it
so there should be a theta hanging at
the end there as required
okay
happy times how do we use this for part
two well unfortunately because it is a
binomial
expansion things are gonna get worse
before they get better but it won't be
too bad okay they've even told you hence
by writing sec theta to the eight in
this particular broken up fashion find
um the integral of sec theta to the
eighth so let's just go ahead and start
off with their question the integral of
sec
theta to the power of eight d theta
i'll just use their substitution that
they've asked me to do but i'm going to
notice that there's a part of this that
will be helpful to break up and a part
of it that will not so just pause for a
moment on this line okay
using the previous result we've got this
uh let's just copy it here we've got
this result over here right sec to the
2n theta now it looks to me like both of
these two terms here in the product in
the integrand they both fit into this
they're both a sec theta to the power of
some even number right this one's 2 this
one's 6. but when you take a brief
moment like i don't want you to simplify
or substitute out blindly i want you to
see why they actually ask you to break
this apart
break this apart into this very unusual
way right
if we are really going to use this
result from part one then you're going
to end up with tans in this integrand
right if you're going to end up with
tens then in terms of the ways to
integrate that reverse chain rule is
probably going to be the most helpful
and the derivative of
10 is sex squared so that's why they
have left this sex squared here and
they've pulled out six of them okay so
what i'm going to do on the next line
just to make it bleedingly obvious is
i'm going to write the first factor in
the integrand as sec to the 2 times 3
there's my 2n
here 2n that's gonna i might as well
highlight it for you that 2n or 2 times
3 rather represents the 2n so i know
what my n will be i'm just going to
leave that sec squared there i i
actually wanted to stay put i'm not
going to substitute it out because
having something which has a lot of sec
terms in it and turning that into
something with a lot of tan terms in it
is just like one you traded one villain
for another right so it's like leave
that that second one there okay it's
going to be fine
all right now i'm going to use my
identity right so this is going to be
according to this
i can just use that to expand like
i'm going to do it turn by turn right so
it's going to have here comes some
brackets i'm going to start at nc 0
except my particular n
is 3 right so i'm going to go
3 choose 0
and then
i
have a think about well ok my first term
if you go back to this version here it
doesn't actually have any tans or tan
squares in it or i should say it's got
zero of them so that's why it doesn't
appear here so i'll leave this 3c 0 by
itself and then i'm going to go 3 c 1
and then tan squared and i'm just going
to keep on going up until i get to in
this case it's going to be 10 to the 6
right so i'm going to have to daisy
3c2
10 to the 4.
and this is where q q varenes comment
about your answer taking up a whole line
it looks like my answer's actually going
to take up more than a whole line so i'm
going to have to rearrange it
but thankfully i can cheat and do that
so let's just grab all of this chuck it
over here because i'm not even finished
writing a line yet right
let's make that a little bit smaller
there we go um that was the sec to the
six theta right so i just got to make
sure this sec squared term is still
hanging out there which you can see came
from there right so it hasn't
disappeared
it's one of the classic things right
like your working memory is so overtaken
by this big expansion that you did that
you forgot to do this thing out the
front it's like when you're doing
volumes of solids of revolution everyone
forgets the pie out the front so it's a
really important thing not to miss any
terms here
okay so now we've got these binomial
coefficients to deal with and just as a
like the way that i do this like just as
a practical thing is that i can see what
each of these numbers is because i know
pascal's triangle like the first few
rows pretty easily this is one three
three
one and i literally just jot that down
for myself just so i have one less thing
that's clogging up my my brain so that i
don't make a silly arithmetic error on
the next line now there's one more thing
i'm going to do as i move into this big
expansion before i integrate which is
it's a bit weird and uncharacteristic
but see how i've got this sex squared
term over here i'm going to multiply it
through by everything just to make it
really obvious how the integration is
going to work you'll see why in a second
okay
so
let's begin with i'll just yeah i'll
chuck some big brackets there i'll start
with the first binomial coefficient
which is just a 1 and then it gets
multiplied by i'll leave that as green
because that's what i wrote there there
we go
um so there's that first term right then
here comes the three from three choose
one i'm going to put in the sec squared
i'll put it in at the end
but this is tan theta
all squared you'll see in a second why
i'm writing it in this way rather than
using the contracted
notation and i'm just going to keep on
going through um i
wasn't meant to make that blue sorry i
just forgot to change my color there we
go
next binomial coefficient is another 3
then you're going to get tan theta
to the 4
the sec squared is there again and then
finally what do we got here plus here
comes my binomial coefficient 1
there's my last tan theta term there's
six of them this time and then the sec
squared that's hanging out on the end
and hopefully you can see even though
it's taking me a bit longer here
you can even see just by looking at it
and seeing my colors you're like oh no
term has been missed i haven't
accidentally you know there's so many
terms here i don't know like 12 15
something like that it's just too easy
to miss one so i just don't trust myself
okay now why did i
go ahead and multiply through by all of
those sec squares well i wanted to make
very obvious for myself that this
tan theta is my f of x and then this sec
squared is my f dash right so you can
see every single time essentially i'm
just doing a reverse chain rule
the alternative to doing it this way is
to just make sure you do a substitution
there but i don't think that's necessary
this makes it pretty obvious for my
brain um working-wise i don't think that
market needs to see this this is more
for me making sure i don't stuff myself
up okay
so i'm pretty much ready to go now i can
integrate i know what the integral of
sec squared is by itself it's just tan
yeah
here i'm going to raise this power by 1
and then i'm going to divide through by
that new power which in this
instance here uh conveniently leaves me
just with the three at the top and
everything else canceled and the sex
squared disappears having divided
through by the derivative of the inside
function which was tan okay
all the rest of them are not quite so
neat so you raise this power by one
becomes five you divide through by that
well it doesn't cancel it just becomes
three fifths right
and what's that ten to the five and then
the last one what do you get
you raise the power up to seven you
divide by that new power so you get a
one seventh hanging out the front
ten to the seven and then don't forget
this is indefinite so you have your
constant integration okay
so they go like i said the state didn't
do well on this question even though
when you compare this to some of the
other integration questions we've had
it's pretty manageable right so i hope
that makes sense and the the layout of
it is pretty clear for you okay though
it is hard like you you don't know what
the result is at the end um so sometimes
with trigger identities you can just
simplify aimlessly not knowing which is
the most helpful way to do it